So, we've talked a bit about what
our tools needs to be able to do.
What tools are out there for us to use?
Most people who make prototypes for
a living work with a lot of tools.
And many of them are very well tailored
for a particular kind of prototype.
Some of the tools people use are
Keynote, Powerpoint, Interactive PDFs,
Balsamiq, Pixate, inVision, and
our good old Pen and Paper.
Don't worry about trying
to remember all of these.
The point is to give you
a sense of what's out there.
In the next video, we'll talk
about what tool we'll be using for
this lesson and why.
Each of these tools has various
strengths and weaknesses, and
each of them will become a part Part
of a mature prototypers tool kit.
Let's get a sense of how each tool
matched up with our
requirements right now.
Keynote is a common tool for when you
want to present a low fidelity prototype
to a group, often within your company.
It's very fast to work with but it's
hard to get remote feedback with and
is non interactive.
PowerPoint is a very similar tool and
it's used for the same reasons.
Again, speed is a strength here, but
there is no built in feedback and
it's not interactive.
Interactive PDFs made with
Adobe InDesign are a common choice for
designers who are workshopping
user experiences.
They are interactive and once you've
put in the work to learn the software,
can be made relatively quickly.
However, they have no
remote feedback options.
Balsamiq, with a Q, is one of the faster
prototyping tools, which allows for
easy iteration but doesn't have
built in remote feedback tools.
Some people combine Balsamiq with
the user testing framework to handle
that portion.
Pixate is a prototyping software
targeted at high fidelity prototyping.
It does interactions,
and a lot of its power
is in the way it deals with micro
interactions and animations.
We'll revisit Pixate in the next lesson.
For now, it's a bit slow for
our purposes.
InVision allows you to create
interactive prototypes quickly, and has
a couple of dedicated tools for getting
remote feedback quickly and effectively.
And finally, our old friend,
the pen and paper, is super fast, but
doesn't allow remote feedback, and
it doesn't allow interactivity.